nein nein nein nein warum es mich doch
nicht weg du sack hatte alter anstatt
auf den anderen zu finden viel besseres
equipment junge service kids und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
mit mir und einem special guest dem wir
müssen namen ausdenken youtube
was ist von der theorie sagen wir
theodor gibt und der wird uns hat bei
der challenge fwg mal hier rein das ist
kurz baby spielen hat die folgende
challenge jeder von uns hat fünf minuten
in quick fire games wohl innerhalb
dieser fünf minuten kriegt er für jeden
kill den er erleidet wir nehmen das
uncut auf eine schelle von der helaba
wie gesagt fünf minuten für jeden
weltlichen teil ein sobald ihr
abgelaufen sind bisher noch dran und für
jeden gibt es innerhalb dieser fünf
minuten für jeden kill 1 1 von theo
danke dir dass du dabei bist und los
geht's ich würde sagen ich von allen
oder bist du anfangen hier haben wir
noch mal ein teil der läuft runter einer
hand dran und es geht los
54 übrigens leute heute ist natürlich im
weihnachten war weihnachten bei uns ja
wir haben da kam mir so ein richtig
geiler sich gehört die kommentare warum
hast du das war nicht wie er das warten
oder wenn also ok tut mir leid wollte
nicht hätten wir haben ein
weihnachtsbaum geschmückt haben unser
weise liegt angehört das war echt der
knaller das lied ging einfach
es riecht es riecht ein
das war der hammer da haben wir haben
wir haben gelacht
fünf minuten lang einfach songtext oh es
riecht gut wo es riecht fein also da
muss jemand sehr ausgiebig gestiftet
haben aber oh ich bekomm ersten schlecht
wahrscheinlich nein
ok sofort vergessen
nein nein nein nein nicht so heftig aus
nein nein nein okay okay
wenn du eine oder zum laufen kriegst du
nicht stirbst dann kannst du theoretisch
auch komplett ohne scheller auskommen
theoretisch man kann natürlich auch
nicht kann natürlich sein dass die
bomben und den weg mit 56 78 kills
eventuell auch 33 aber wenn man am ende
bekommt und nicht gewinnt ist nicht
alles gut was
ja aber er ist auch nicht so krank ist
er will jetzt nicht der andere kommt
jedoch auf mich du sack hat der alte das
gibt es nicht warum geht er jetzt auf
mich man es ist mega und für nein warum
ich noch nicht wegsackte alter anstatt
auf den anderen zugehen und viel
besseres equipment junge aber wie es
weitergeht aber ich habe noch 30
sekunden überstehen
sie hat mir vorstellen es gibt eine
kiste warst du
1 und wie steht's um stets so als ob das
technisch nicht okay
drei steps habe ich glaube ich bekomme
ich bin dreimal gestorben hat dieser
fünf minuten
ich spiele jetzt so zu ende und dann
springen wir zu maxi fünf minuten die er
dann auch bestellt
den speck leute ohne nummer 2 count down
läuft was dran
ich seh oder ist zur stelle und
gewaltbereit und diese rechte gerne mal
hier zwischen die augen setzen wird
gesagt dass er jan karin ob ich ein
schläger haben will nicht mehr reden
er hat gesagt also janka noch härter
schlagen wir sie ja ja ja wollte sich
würde ich sagen dass ich wirklich
geschlagen auch weil es ein eisen
schwertern ene stein der im altersheim
ok muss natürlich auch umgehender und
seiner kate geht an troja der antiken
via chess kampf doom ii und dessen stört
er wird direkt mit kick off frechen
eltern abbrechen
vor allem schnell oder warum bist du so
gestört drei minuten 20 auf dem
countdown das nächste mal wirklich nicht
alles klar 88 junge noch ein kleiner
tipp für mich geben wir zur wichtigkeit
start läuft eigentlich aber kids bringen
wie gesagt so gesehen schon die in einem
vollkommen bescheidene krippner dir das
mal dem gar kein saft war eine tolle
reisen schwert alter
was macht er sogar zwei eisen schwerter
stück in sein haus geholt dass zwei
stücke und wie es läuft hast du noch 31
eventuell ist er mit nur einem slapshot
spieler nur noch junge team da kommt
erst jetzt ermöglichte slaiten beispiel
da noch hinter seiner haben alle viel
schlechter zu kippen dazu man so alt
ermutigt der drop mutig mutig mutig
mutig mutig und tnt runde gewonnen
aber es aber nicht da war
55 sekunden
sie könnten ihr glorreich verbracht ok
ich hab' klasse ich habe einmal geworden
wurde nur zweimal geschlagen insgesamt
eindeutig besser gestorben
am ende nicht gewonnen